hi I'm Timothy Verde I'm gonna give a
talk called
hands-on neural network for natural
language processing
okay so while you are downloading and
matters we'll do the introduction so so
we don't lose time because we have a we
own very tight schedule with all the
material we are here
so welcome everyone to this workshop
about application of neural network to
natural language processing its natural
language processing is obviously a
pretext to get familiar with with neural
networks with evaluation of the neural
network usage of the neural networks and
basically what we're going to see today
can be used on anything that is
sequenced by based so it can works also
for signals like like audio text which
is the main basis for for natural
language processing for you you might
have video sequence of images and so on
and so on and so on
right it's it's going to be both a
primer on neural network because we're
going to start with with the best basic
evaluation training and so on and very
advanced course on on network
architecture and so so we're going to do
that is by following rocket-launch path
ok so so so if if i don't have any any
interruption any question i would
probably give more and more momentum to
the presentation so that we go as far as
possible which is probably the best way
for you not to ever come back home with
with all your parts so you're very
welcome to interrupt me to ask question
to try things and to make this workshop
a real workshop instead of just
listening to the talk which is not what
this is meant to be and in also because
it's natural language just quick remand
reminder about it
if you if you ask me what's natural
language is we don't sir it's French but
you might ask question in English also
and I do my best to well process in
English so that's it and I will I will
try to leave the URL a bit but we need
to move on okay so so first natural
question to ask to start with workshop
I'm starting assuming that the audience
is very broad in knowledge about neural
networks so first question is probably
what's a neural network scholar answer
would be basically it's a differential
transformation on ng array that's give
you the ID the way I explain my work to
to my friends so they I keep France is
basically it's it's a transformation it
takes blah and it makes another thing
out of it and it has some some some some
buttons that you can gently smoothly
change move in order to tune the
transformation and you can move the
position and therefore you can seek a
good transformation by playing author
and colder Rama Rama Rama and trying to
get to to a soft spot right so just ends
that done for the yes you should run it
should run on any version of Mathematica
which is which official bits if you have
the beta release of the of the version
12 that should be given to you BAE for
the fuzzy state conference is that the
one and hundred person Church completely
works on because I Barret proofed it
well at least on the back at least on
this
okay so quick tour but what we're going
to do is to start with the foundation so
we're gonna just get an old Network
model and and see what it's like
evaluate it and and move to the anatomy
dissection room try to take apart the
components see see what they look like
and these dismember the neural network
we assemble it and then from these
bricks we're gonna see we can build
houses which is several different
architecture of neural network we we can
those houses are like modules you can
assemble to get C keys and so on and so
on and so on
right and we will focus on a family of
this transformation which are a sick
sequence type of structure but once you
have the understanding of how this works
you could basically navigate in for any
type of application right so let's start
first thing you need to do is to
evaluate the first line that's the only
time I will tell you how to evaluate a
cell which is shift answer on the shell
you just can be answered no to any
question this stuff asks and you get
your neural network right so and I know
using the match of your notebook you
should have and what we are downloading
here I'm not gonna say much but the
neural network repository but just know
that there is a very there's probably a
talk about it already
or to come but there is a huge library
of network models and architecture you
can download and use directly opens open
sourced on the Internet you can get them
and do whatever you want with them you
can even export export them to other
formats in and get away with them right
so if you're inside a notebook if you
have nothing that you can join running
then you can use the net model function
and you only need to know what you're
looking for which is the name of your
model and if you don't know the name of
your model you can browse the website
that
so here is the the first model I
introduce you to which is this network
so basically basic basic one you just
see it looks like a stacked and symbol
of what seems to be called layers with
values name and so we have we have a we
have an input an entry and we haven't
had an output so first things to do once
we have a network which is know called
net is to try to evaluate it on
something and since I'm on mathematic an
evaluating on this symbolic formula and
the symbolic formula is something that
the network cannot swallow so it's gonna
yell at me just saying that this is an
invalid inputs because input was not a
string so this network wants a string
and let's provide it with a string and
you see just I would put a new string as
a single character so basically this
network is a long edge model means it
was trained on the sequence of character
to predict the most likely next
character or the likelihood of the
possible next character right so you
give it a string it assume it's a
context string it says given this
context what's going to follow okay
you can also batch evaluate that is
evaluate in parallel the network on
several input so this is what which is
the most likely string even given wah
and if you evaluate on on what we where
we me whatever you got what when and
which which is the best guess that the
network can give you and why do I show
you the batch evaluation it's because
one of the very powerful feature of the
neural network is that there are heavily
parallel is able it means that you can
paralyze a computation and you're gonna
get a lot of speed improvement just to
show you we're going to just get an
example data which is the text of Alice
in Wonderland
right I'm not showing it because it's
gonna blow the netbook and there is this
function here that I have written for
you what it does it simply pick random
location in the text and extract Oh
snippets of ten characters that's basic
things we can feed the network with in
order to get the next character right so
test data would be some random snippet
extraction in the stairs of and let's
take 500 of them we can look at what
it's like right it's a snippet of the
text in Alice in the Wonderland and we
can submit them in two different manner
to the network first one is mapping that
is second surely passing the string to
the network or batching that is giving
all the all the other strings at once
right and which we should obtain the
same result so it's same queue of the
map and the batch right so true says
it's exactly the same thing whether we
pass it second chose as a batch and but
you can see that the timing here looks
like we have at least a factor of 6 in
terms of of computation right so if you
can with your computer and if you manage
to download and follow me up to here you
have evaluated
maybe you first oh maybe you first
Mathematica network or maybe you just
availability the network that's and
that's enable us to move to the next
step which is try to try to go and make
some surgery on on this network because
it's what networks are interesting at
it's to be to be cut apart and to be
reassemble like it's it's really Lego
transformation so as this network is a
shame what we're going to do is we're
going to extract first part of the
network then one step further and so on
and so on and so on
and and we will follow the flow of of
the of the information at each step the
they are processed right so first I told
you neural networks that some things
that work on numerical nd array so like
big bunch of numbers and strings are not
officially numbers so this neural
network in neural network in Mathematica
are not pure neural network they have
something called net encoder at the
input could be there which is an
interpreter if you if you like which is
going to translate the input into the
numeric world and so so this net encoder
is expecting some some character and is
returning a vector so a sequence of n
indices between 1 and 97 so this net
encoder knows 97 characters and for each
character will generate a number right
very basic each character as its
synthesis you can get rid of this
pre-processing step getting rid of the
net encoder but replacing the input
parts of the network and putting
automatic which is the network is no
expecting numbers right so so row net
will know yell if I if I give him if I
give it a string okay
so first part of the network is just
generating a list of of indices for each
character in the string no this is not
very rich encoding right basically being
two character next to one another
doesn't tell us much about whether we
are similar like there is no real reason
for a big next to be and far from C or
from oh I think but so what we can do is
to to take this information and move it
in another space that is richer and that
the student step if we extract the first
stage of the of the
actual network which is what I'm doing
here and say take take inside the net
which is a stack of liquor and a chain
of the year take inside the net up to
the layer one and I get a new net chain
so a new stack of layer which goes from
input to the first part and then the
output is just whatever is processed and
I can look at what's what what the
result of using this beheaded net on on
the data on larger and larger string so
W gets transformed by the the
pre-processing to 90 and 90 gets
transformed to a vector so this first
this first stage of the network is
called an embedding what it does it just
picks a picks the numbers index and do a
look at inside the table of vector
saying oh 90 here is your vector why do
I want to do that because vectors are
much richer in terms of the vector space
is much richer on what I can encode then
that just the number right and therefore
I can use those vector to encode some
semantic of my problem and that's all
embeddings are about because those
numbers those vector they're going to be
learned okay and what does it yes yes
yes so I don't know which cleaner you
prefer but basically you the first part
the pre-processing just outputs the
integer of the first character that is
94w and and this first figure is just a
table of vector and gonna pick the 19th
victor no no this lookup table is
basically a table of random vector which
values have been tuned during the
learning phase of the network so so so
this one this this table was tuned in
order to have some semantic inside the
Victoire direction if you want that will
help the victor to solve the task that
is hmm given those character what is the
next that is coming okay so I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna show you that example
that is Mary maybe more more easy to
understand so so indeed if I can I can
if I get right if I get rid of the of
the of the pre-processing step
I can just pass the values of the of the
index and make the lookup in the tag in
the in the table and you see that indeed
the first vector that is victim and the
90s always is always the same and I'm
just you know going from a sequence of
integer to index to a sequence of vector
why do I want to do that this is
something if you have passions or if you
can in time to download globe which is a
very well-known embedding it's something
that I can show you so glove was trained
nuts for animating on characters but on
words level that is each word gets a
number so I have vocabulary let's call
it a dictionary it says boat number 25
then globe is number 25 boats what do I
get
and it will give me a vector and it was
trained on a task to predict next work
or to predict actually globe was trying
to predict how close works with whether
I can substitute one word for another in
a sentence so the idea is that similar
vector in term of direction should have
similar meaning right directions is
direction on a sphere on the nd sphere
it's very 50 dimensional sphere in so
the distance because the cosine distance
you take the angle you look how big is
the angle 0 is very close it's the same
and then it goes to 1 or 2 depending on
what you divided by P or 2 pi or
whatever so let's try it
so evaluates word distance and tries a
word distance that is just taking the
vectors and computing the cosine
distance between them
and what it says said that sheep and
goats or sheep I don't know one of the
two are close together right 0.1 is
quite close
so they're some they share some
semantics that boat and carrots doesn't
have a lot to do together
but that carrot and zucchini are
somewhat related in the order of
magnitudes that boat and ship are right
yes that yeah it's blue of 50
dimensional saying that you get a factor
of size 50 and also the bigger your
space the more information you can
encode but tests on that showed that
there is a soft spot for most of the
embeddings that people have been
training you're somewhat between 50 and
300 seems to be the right values and
then depending on how how how heavy you
want your network to be how fast you
want it to be computed you will pick one
of those sorry it's the the paper read
we're saying that between 50 and 300
it's somewhat the the good the good
spots but this was for natural language
and for this specific task that is
similarity between words right so so we
have this list of vectors and if we have
an embedding that was previously trained
we have some semantics but we might also
have an embedding that is just you know
random Blanc from start and we will
train it later so we have a sequence of
vector and now we're going to process
them and given the fact that we are
focused on SiC on sequence here I'm
gonna introduce you to the next stage so
let's take Network one two two and and
well actually let's see what's what's
stage two is doing it's called drop out
layer
and basically this is a little guys that
is doing nothing right so if you take
the first step and you tap up to the
second layer it's exactly the same thing
so let's forget about this guy maybe we
come back later maybe nuts it's it's
something we're not very interested in
at the moment it's not doing anything at
evaluation so let's take up to the third
stage here is the new net input and
bedding layer drop out layer we forgot
about its its identity and gated
recurrent layer rake current layer
so regular layer is familiar layer what
they are doing is taking a sequence and
generating a sequence so processing your
sequence and why they are called
recurrent is because they are using a
recurrence relation that is they're
maintaining the backward loop that is
feeding back state some information
about the the previous computations
inside the next computation right so
it's it's an object that maintain a
state of what happened and use it in the
next and then you have large family of
of them and we're going to use this this
gated recurrent layer as a representant
of the family you can basically use any
others it will be somewhat close in
terms of results so that's the ID you
have your sequence you send your
sequence victor victor per vector inside
your layer your layer
do some computation generate a new
vector and this new vector or some part
of the computation is fed back into the
area for the next computation so we have
this memory of what happened okay and
and we can we can look up what's going
on so we had three three victor after
the meeting we still have three vector
they might be of different size you know
the unbanning was size 1997 the
dissembling was of size 97 inside this
this
work and the gated recurrent network is
generating vector of size 512 okay so
there are some matrix multiplication and
you have an input which is 97 and an
output which is 512 right so just a
quick overview of houses gated recurrent
layer work it's very simple we have this
with net pots input we have a net pot
that is the initial state so the first
value we're going to feed to start the
recurrence and then we just feed back
the output of the network as the next
state right so we're we are doing a
recurrent layer you will provide me one
vector and an initial state which is
zero if you don't say anything I will do
some computation and give you a new
vector I will also keep a copy of it so
if you give me a second vector I will
use it as a state to compute the third
one the second one and give it to you
and keep a copy for the third one and so
on and so on and so on it's not very
simple you can code your your own layer
if you want so let's let's have a let's
have a basic graph this is your first
graph we will generate a graph having a
single recurrent layer which is actually
the third layer of the net we use we're
going to just extract the third layer
and we go we're going to input we're
going to use one entry for this network
which is net pot input which is called
input and which will feed will be fed to
the recurrent layer and we will use
another entry which is called initial
state which will be fed to the entry
states of the recurrent layer easy so
you get a net graph says I have two and
three two ports initial and initial
state and inputs and I'm giving you
something on the Potts output and then
we will evaluate this this graph which
is a single layer on the input first
step net of the value so the embedding
of that
you and feeding a constant array of zero
as initial state okay just to show you
what's going on we get a new vector now
if you're not familiar with I introduced
you to fold lists
what's all this is doing is just
generating a recursive evaluation so for
lists of X and the list is just giving
you X then f of X and a and then F of F
the X and a and B and so on and so on
over the list so and that's exactly what
the recurrent layer is doing so if I do
for lists of this of this subject and
since it outputs a sequence of size 1 I
can just take the elements and feeding
and feeding back this element over again
as initial States so I'm feeling back
and really initializing the network over
and over again with its output I'm just
getting exactly the same F as the
network produce right sick F D so now so
this is basic processing unit for
sequence know if I want to process more
in order to enrich my transformation and
another somewhat richer family of
transformation I can stack them so
that's what the network is actually made
of it's 3 staking staked stacked
recommend layer together right so let's
extract the the network and that's so
you you cannot treat me being a liar
here you have your three gated recurrent
layer and and then each layer is doing
the same taking the output of the of the
of the one before him and doing this
recurs this recursive evaluation with
its own state and generating a sequence
so the size of the sequence is not
changing at all okay I see that you are
super impressed
okay so the task is from a sequence to a
single prediction so in order to
generate the single output we will
choose a representative of the sequence
and because it's arbitrary for me and
because there is some processing going
on over the sequence with the recursion
a good choice seems to take the last one
I'm processing the sequence the last
element has seen as it was computed with
the state that takes as memory of all
that happened before let's take it as
the encoding of the sequence right so
next layer
not very interesting let's just look at
this guy is called sequence left layer
and it's doing exactly what it called
you look at the sequence it just takes
the last one right and and and after
that so I have this layer of size 512
which is which is a representative of my
of my sequence and I want to generate a
prediction over something that is size
97 because it's a number of character I
want to describe right what I'm going to
predict is the probability for each
character to follow what I've seen 97
character this could probably discrete
probability distribution of a 97
character right so let's let's make a
linear combination of all the
information that are inside this this
representative of the sequence and and
generates something that is size 97 okay
that's a projection of the information I
have that I will learn I will learn how
to project this information into some
things that I want to interpret as being
probability distribution so linear layer
it's purely matrix multiplication with
weight of the matrix being learned
let's see that boom
so gate either gated sequence last
linear layer if I look I can click on
each layer and have information about it
it's telling me that I have oh that's
impressive matrix of size 97 times 512
so those are the number of weights each
weight is used to do the projection it's
simply a matrix but if I want to
interpret this projection as being an
actual distribution of probability I
need to normalize it and the standard
normalization is the so-called soft
markets normalization right it's taking
the existing sure everyone is positive
by taking the exponential and it's
normally it's normalizing of Azusa and
if you've done some physics it's
somewhat something you have seen about
the energy and so on you have the
exponential of minus something over the
sum of this and this is a very
interesting object that is doing some
great thing that is the reason why
everybody loves it
so that's the softmax layer right it
takes it takes a vector and generate a
probability distribution for each
element of the vector of being a
probability and everything sums to 1 so
we know the full neural network and we
have seen detail by just taking a path
and you know and now you know how to do
some surgery on the network take some
parts extract some Pat and so on and we
know see what's going on there we are
just generating a number with this net
encoder those number do some new cap
operation in a table that generates a
sequence of vector so this vector are
processed three time by bio recursion
with some computation with learned
learned parameters then the output of
this only the last part is selected
selected and projected in a different
space of the appropriate size and then
it's normalized to get a distribution
and what I want is tuning all the
weights in this guy in order to get that
does this transformation actually fit
and match the distribution of
probability so learn the district fits
the distribution of probability of the
characters last thing as you can
pre-process the input you can also post
process the output depending on your
needs so a layer as a net decoder
attached to it which is taking this
probability distribution which is the
thing you actually learning and
generating information depending on what
you ask properties so you can say net of
WH a but this time I want the top
probabilities and I want three of them
and we says okay
I gave you t as a prediction because it
has probability 97% but there is also
one point one point seven percent of
probability being L because you can it's
not only what it's also it's also Wales
and things like that
right and and you can also say well
maybe this network is a bit too
confident so I will change the
temperature which is basically a
multiplicative factor inside the
exponential very great physical meaning
still I will change this temperature so
multiply everything in this vector here
before I do the softmax so that's the
probability which are first in the log
space they became closer or further
apart by this multiplication so this
making the distribution some smooth
server or more picked and so high
temperature is something where everyone
is a bit the same and low temperature is
something in which in which only the
best choice is selected all the rest is
going to 0 right and so exercise
that I will leave to you and you have
the solution here because we need to
move on is evaluate sale how do we is
how do you generate a sentence
recursively using the long wait model
saying like pegs the next character
choose a character sample from the
distribution and so on and so on
and you have this finished sentence here
that generates a sequence of character
with the temperature of one up to a
hundred and character by character
starting by WH it generates something
that looks like English right so who
works for the stats and then wondered
why she was I stopped at two hundred I
can change the temperature and says for
instance temperature of three so what it
stops every time there is a return of
singe with the temperature of three I
have a lots of punctuation and things
that I haven't accept or sentence so
it's it's fairly random right so
generation so we will stop quite soon or
generate some crap and with the
temperature or the row points one for
instance it will just just pick the best
likely character in and so you will see
patterns again and again and again sorry
no that's some things that I've hand
coded and that you it's it's really easy
to just multiply here before before you
do the before you do the evaluation so
you just take out the softmax do your
multiplication and normalize by hand so
it's reported since 11.1 mike first sure
and so so so probably i use a trick that
is twelve but the ID is the same and and
and some things that you may think is
how do i generate the next character by
feeling again and again the sequence
that grows right and so every time the
network is recomputing the world
sequence and moving on and the sequence
grows and grows and grows and this is a
lot of computation for things I already
know because I have already done the
first step so one good idea would be as
a second exercise exercise and this is
something that is new in 11.3 and in 12
the second exercise would be keep keep
the state keeps it keep it and just feed
the next character so you just loop the
next character and you save the state
inside your your recursive Network so
that you generate only character per
character very fast right and this is
the finished sentence - and last one
which is also an interesting one is
given the fact that I can just compute
the probability of the next character I
can compute the probability of the of a
word inside a string right it's just the
product of the probability for each
characters and therefore I can compute
the probability of putting a word inside
some context left and right and this is
here it says that I am very tired of
working as is somewhat ten to the minus
seven it's not normalized but that's you
can compare one to one the probabilities
that probability of being happy of
working is less probable that's in terms
of what it the network has met and
learned the probability of being very
banana of walking is somewhat to the
minus 15 and the probability of being
very valued of walking is 10 to the
minus 25 so you can see you can see and
you can have a way to actually say oh
this word baby or neuro and things like
that right ok so let's move on to to
training so very small data set movie
review of data and we're going to use a
very similar architecture to
to classifies sentences so you have a
movie review saying Oh Afghan sees this
movie and it was really really bad
and you have to say automatically
depending on the sequence of character
whether this is positive or not and you
have a data set for that so here are a
few examples in our yo- you are not
merely watching history your angle foot
engulfed by its positive you have to be
English speaker on spoke starting
hanging out at the Berber shot they
never wanted to leave chance I want in
anyway that's that such a data set okay
so I have a few have examples like this
and I want to network to do that for me
automatically based on the example I
want to learn this distribution this
probability distribution so it's a
probability distribution instead of
having characters like ninety seven
possibility
I just classify with two outcomes and I
want the probability of the sequence to
be positive or negative and I'm training
it directly onto the example so same
thing I take the character I generate a
lookup table which is stats random and
then will be tuned and from this lookup
table I'm moving into a regular layer
I'm just putting one just to see what it
leads us and then taking the last
element of the sequence after processing
as the representative of the sentence
projecting it in a vector of size two
and normalizing it okay easy
first this encoding stage which is
basically all this way up to the to the
single vector here as a representative
encoding the sentence so and then
decoding is probably not the right word
here but it's classifying I take this
representant of the sentence and I'm
making a decision an educated guess or
at least I'm estimating its value right
so two nets which are just mentioned
that is ice taxes Lydia together and I
put an encoder at the at the at the
beginning and and this encoder is
encoded token that is I'm not taking
just the character but I'm taking words
for the lookup table
okay so I'm training my own little glue
and you see that the vector will be of
size 40 and gated recurrent without boot
size 32 and this is completely arbitrary
that's because I like it and that
because it worked
somehow okay and then the sentiment note
is that the the encoding following by
the classify right here we have and it's
great saying like some some weights have
bins are not set yet and they will be
affected random value at the training
time so let's train how do I train I
give the network to net train
I give training data which is just a
list of rules saying this is positive
this is negative and so on and so on and
so on and I want all the output of net
train and I'm putting some validation
data which is data I'm not providing to
the network at the training time being
the teacher of the network I keep some
exercise for the for the for the test
right I'm feeding the network with
exercise is trying to learn and then I
can validate that I learned something ok
and let's look at what's going on there
so so this is so the network is training
in orange you have the the curves of the
of the the validations of the objective
getting warmer or colder and blue is the
actual value on on the testing data so
you see that is basically learning the
sentence by yet so it can be really good
at classifying you see the aurochs close
to zero on the sentence that is already
seen but is like more like 20% of what
is a new day a new a new object so it's
really important to have this validation
in your data set so you can compare but
without doing nothing but providing the
architecture I have a network which has
learned to be 97% good accurate on the
training set and 76 percent correct on
just putting
number of star on the video brain shock
based on the text you given right random
one would have been 50% because there is
two to solution so we learn something
okay
and we can try and that's where the drop
out layer we seen together that's layers
that is effective only at training we
can try to to shake the data by putting
random value to zero so that each each
data we provide is a bit different from
the from the usual data and it's harder
to learn by Hertz so it has to find a
more meaningful and general is able
transformation so that's the main idea
of dropout layer is putting some some
variance on the data so that the network
has a harder time at just learning by
Hertz the data set so just putting a
drop out of of point three saying 30% of
the value of the vector will be randomly
set to zero and move on with that but
only at training time and same network
just adding a layer and and the idea
would be for it to follow it's a bit
further a bit more the actual actual
training but it's not a bulletproof
solution so if your data if you have
very small data set like this I've just
a few few thousands of the example maybe
10,000 that I have spit in training and
testing shaking the data won't be enough
so you need more data in order to get
better performance okay but that that's
that's the idea of dropouts and all
those that make sure that the network is
learning some things that generalize are
called regularization system okay so we
can stop it we see that it's going
nowhere in terms of is still learning
but learning more a moba by hertz so we
stop and we can see maybe we generally
buy a bit better
we've got ninety eighty percent instead
of 70 76 right so
or what I can do is saying like oh you
have too much degrees of freedom inside
the embeddings the local table you can
store all the information there so I can
freeze it at training say let's use this
twenty five dimensional vector but you
don't touch it and I use vectors that
have been learned on the different tasks
with a much bigger data sets
that's called transfer learning and
that's very efficient for small tasks
right so do the same replace my
embedding by an embedding that I will
throw that training how do I do that I
do that by net trained learning rate
multiplayer the first the first element
in my in my network which is in the
encoders first layer so one one as a
learning rate multiplier of not saying
I'm not learning there okay and and I
can do that also and I will have I will
have another training with with with a
different curve and and possibly be key
because I have less degrees of freedom I
will less over fit right and that you
see that the training is slower but
eventually if I wait for those three
minutes I would get better results
okay I won't wait so now let's move on
to more interesting tasks so this has
been a reclassification I take a
sequence I look for probably two your
decision but more interestingly are a
question answering so I've got a secret
I've got to sequence one sequence is the
context and the other the next sequence
is a question about the context so I'm
downloading this if if I can I've got
this is baby question answering data set
which is something like omaree's in the
kitchen Mary moved to the to the CAD
board Murray exits a cab board and and
moved to another room where's Mary
and sometimes you say oh by the way mark
arrived at the place some random
information I provide that to the
network I provided the question I want
the question st. Mary's in the in the in
the kitchen so the idea is that
I have a problem with the sequence I
will choose a representative so
basically what I'm going to do is
sequence lastly you're on the encoding
of the question I'm coding the question
and question so okay and encoding the
context and coding the question taking a
representative for them all stacking
them together so this is a context and
the question and doing the
classification so you see that that's
very similar right so same thing you
should be able as an exercise to
generate the question answer in net and
training on the data right so this time
and this is so so we can follow a bit
what's going on there so you see that
the that's good because the validation
is following is following the actual
training accuracy and and and so this is
a loss this is a prediction on the
probability distribution and then there
was like picking the best the best guess
and if we look at the accuracy this time
just by counting the just that contains
the actual good answer of the network
which is that for something like
so typical context Mary went back to the
bedroom Mary traveller to the bathroom
so on where is Daniel and Daniel is in
the kitchen right so you see that I can
predict / / 1 2 3 4 6 different solution
and I get one one one time out of two a
good the correct one I can try to
improve this by changing the
architecture to something more powerful
which is maybe one vector to encode the
context is too small and since I'm not
overfitting let's let's have a stronger
detector that is I encode the question
is one vector but I'm going to keep the
full sequence as as as for the context
I'm going to stack them together and
then I'm going to protest this sequence
to generate a representative of the
answer make sense okay so same same
Network generating some classification
and I train so so so this time same same
type of network but I keep the wall
sequence and I'm going to just stack the
question or representative over each
word of the context and this will maybe
help the system to figure out a easier
way the answer right and and the
learning goes and that's that's that's a
good learning because actually that was
a good learning because big because
actually but they don't get me much so
next idea is to see actually this this
this this encoding of the of the of the
context should depend on the question
because depending on the question I'm
asking I should look at different parts
of the code of the context and this is a
new layer that I'm introducing year
which
called the attention layer and what it
does it takes each it so generates some
values and some in some keys for that
for the photo for the further context
and what its gonna do is the the keys
are representative of the elements in
the context regarding the queries and
for each element in the query I'm going
to look at all element in the context
and look for the one that is the closest
in terms of similarity so if the
question is about Mary it will match
where Mary appears in the context so and
then out of those similarity will
generate a list of weights saying I want
to pay more attention at this part of
the context you know this is a soft max
over just the dot product of the query
times the keys and I will multiply the
values by the saying like this is this
this element I want to look at this
mixture of elements of the context right
and then process as usual take the take
the output of this of this mixture stack
the question on top of it generate this
Lee this sequence a recurrence which is
no decoding recurrence
lastly year and classification so
so training again and what we see here
is that instead of those with this
attention instead of those 96% of
basically going down to zero which is
that the network is if the network is
able to span attention over the context
is able to solve perfectly the task that
is on that if we look at the accuracy so
let's let's stop the training yeah if we
look at the exerc that's on the on the
test data so that I never seen it's a
hundred percent that is that this task
is definitely t2e it can be fitted
perfectly right even the new data points
so attention is some other great help
further and and no because we have a few
time left let's let's move to to a new
type of task so this is a great family
of tasks which is you see with with
three lines of code just stacking some
transformation together providing some
strings in like a question string and a
sequence of context you get an automated
answer of where is Mary and so that
classification is is one very great
funny of tasks for sequence sentiment
analysis all of the of the the other
comment on the web are rated this way
because there are too many for for you
man correct or right no no what we we
can we want to be able to do sometimes
is to actually generate a sentence so
that it's like you ask a question I want
the answer or you want to translate
translation is I have a sequence of
words in the language and I want a
sequence of word in a different language
right so one toy example of of
translation which I can show you here
it's to generate given lists
of integrals a list of strings that are
integers okay probably this is going to
be the next example that if you if
you're not satellite that's probably a
lot of things to digest so if you have a
list of string that are just 8 0 9 4 1
let's let's take another one it would be
maybe so I'm gonna I'm gonna give you 4
4 string of integers and I want you to
translate that saying salting the
integer in order saying like I have 1 0
& 1 1 & 2 8 and 1 9
that's a translation right you're moving
from a sequence to a new sequence which
is basically saying the same thing in a
different world in a different manner
so I'm going to do that and one one way
to do that is to actually take the
representative of the encoding of the
sequence of the first sequence first
sequence regular embedding recurrently
your representative of the sequence and
use it as it's as a state for another
recurrent layer which will be given the
next character every time so it should
generate right it says like okay first
word is 1 then I will give you okay here
is the state here is the first word
what's in the next word in the sentence
and therefore would generate a new
sequence ok and so so the way I I will I
will train is given the given the input
so I have the input sequence which is 7
2 1 1 2 I have the target in the example
we start with the beginning of the
target then the correct answer then end
of the answer and then the network will
be provided this sequence and this is
this is how it's gonna happen I'm going
to provide the encoding for 7 2 1 1 2
and this encoding it will try to decode
it by generating a sequence and we said
ok first element is start of
it would say okay my answer is to write
I take this I take this - and I feed it
back to the network or actually I take
the the next tournament so so instead of
feeding back the answer of the network I
hid it back the correct answer right so
I take the correct the next tournament I
feed it to the network he said oh my
answer is on the correct answer was
actually and the correct answer was
actually one I feed back the correct
answer one to the network and he said my
answer is still and it's a bad network
that was the correct one and so on and
so on and so on until until the I reach
the end of of the of the sequence and
then we will compare the unserved the
network with the with with a correct
answer and give a feedback to the
network
that's called teacher forcing I provide
every time I correct the network by
giving putting me back on the track and
I try to generate sequence this way and
[Music]
and if you want to see the training
that's that's here and we're gonna stop
there you can you your feel free to to
carry on with with a netbook but on this
translation task you see that the the
network after a few of you that one
minutes of training is already good at
only this six percent euro rate so the
network is able to translate from this
one two three blah blah blah to the
sorted order in natural language and by
replacing these by Japanese character
and the correct output you can do
exactly the same to do automated
translation right so let's stop it here
and no to generate the result instead of
we don't have the right answer anymore
so we will just feedback the answer of
the network at each step so make your
best guest use the best guess to do the
next and so on and so on step by step
okay and this is called 3d decoding
because I only keep the best guess but I
could explore more in the in in time for
every time I've got see if I've got
enough nine word in my vocabulary the
next step I have nice possibility so
there's nine for each then and it grows
exponentially so I have to choose one
way to explore this tree and pick the
probability into the into the object so
greedy decoding let's let's see what the
network has this is the encoding of the
sequence I have to I have to take the
decoding part of the net as an
independent net to feedback the encoding
and generate from it right
so I evaluates the encoding
independently of the decoding and I
generates I will use inside this decoder
in order to feed the next element over
and again I will use the trick of
keeping the weight of my network so I
will use a net state objects that
maintain the weight after one evaluation
and make it's ready to to be fed with
the next example and now I can start to
to greedily could string one three three
four two and he said I have one one I
have two - which is which is obviously
wrong and two three which is good and
one eight right and if I change if if I
change the if I if I so if I if I turn
it longer or if I turn it with with a
different idea texture which I was going
to show you which is the architecture
with attention to
I was with attention you will reach a
hundred percent accuracy on this on this
task right I think we need to really
stop there thank you for your attention
[Applause]